women terrible things happen to people
of both sexes and you could say that
with with with perfect utility but that
doesn't provide any evidence for the
existence of a male-dominated patriarchy
well that just means the terrible things
happen to both genders which they
certainly do but there are almost no
women who rape men for example so that
is an asymmetry there in sexual violence
well yes there's a there's an asymmetry
in all sorts of places but that doesn't
mean that western culture is a
male-dominated patriarchy the fact that
there are asymmetries has nothing to do
with your basic argument no but you
um
her statement first of all
she needs to know her facts and know
that how to quote a book before she
comes he said no this is what i actually
said in the book it's like okay
it's
real quick he said actually no this is
what it's in the but she's like oh i say
it tell her let her know but
her her statement on um
grape and the with
men and
women and men i don't think that
they're i don't think that it's not
happening i just think that
men don't say anything from
what
what i've heard in different situations
men don't say anything because it's like
oh you let a woman do that to you how do
you do that why don't you overpower her
from my knowledge and i don't think that
is
a valid
um
stat to give in what he's saying and
everything well and
i have heard a lot of stories about
young guys getting taken advantage of
from like cougars or like middle-aged
moms or it was like my friend's mom made
a move on me
and we're just not in a society where
like
it's common for men to come forward
about about that stuff i think it's more
common than like really the numbers
would show yes i do believe that if it
was if it wasn't
a thing where someone would
take it and like make fun of you from it
in a men's perspective i think more and
more men would come forward and say
something
no matter how great no matter no matter
what the situation is i think that
statistic would be
vastly similar or just
different well did you see the live date
that i did i had like no i wasn't able
to watch well he you know it's i brought
on um
a guy and a girl to go on a live date on
this show right and one of the questions
i asked was
have either of you ever cheated right
and he tells me this story about how
this girl like he's like passed out and
like went on top of it i was not i was
like i'm so sorry you did not have to
say that question
um and his girlfriend like broke up with
him over it
that's what yeah and i was like
that's like assault how
not like that yeah yeah
i i had a friend that had a similar
story like that like the he was asleep
and the girl just started to do things
to him while he was sleeping he woke up
and was like yo like what are you doing
and so it's like
people and he like told his friends he
was like nah like that didn't happen you
were awake
and
it's just i think yeah it's tough
you might see this is a trope that
people just accept western society is a
male-dominated patriarchy it's like no
it's not
that's not true and and even if it even
if it has a patriarchal structure to
some degree
the uh the fundamental basis of that
structure is not power it's competence
that's why our society works it's only
when as when a
structure degenerates into tyranny that
the fundamental relationships between
people become dependent on power
it's not power if you hire a plumber
who's likely to be male
it's not because there's roving bands of
tyrannical plumbers forcing you to make
that choice and it's the case with
almost every interaction that you have
at the face of our culture you're
dealing with people who are offering a
service of one form or another who are
usually part of the broad middle class
and who offer and what you're looking
for is the person who can offer the best
service and you can find it it's not a
consequence of being dominated by
anything that's tyrannical and and then
again our culture or the western culture
which is by no means perfect and
certainly has tyrannical elements like
all cultures do is the least tyrannical
society that's ever been produced and
certainly the least tyrannical society
that exists now so where's the
patriarchy exactly in all well saying
that it's the least tyrannical society
is not the same as saying it's not a
tyrannical society that's exactly why i
said it was the least but that's what i
mean so you haven't debunked the
existence of patriarchy then you've said
that actually now is better you don't
have to debunk women to demonstrate its
existence okay well let's go through it
i'm writing a book about feminism in the
moment uh until 1919 there were
professions that women were barred from
they simply were not allowed to do it
until 1880 why would you blame men for
that
because who was in those professions who
was guarding entry to those professions
who was worried about losing their
status if women became indoctrinated
women in the 20th century just out of
curiosity well a couple of different
things i think it was technology i think
it was the pill helped enormously
because it was that development in the
60s right so that wasn't 1919. no but i
also think it was a series of legal
changes that started in britain with the
married women's property act which said
for the first time women are full legal
beings under the law they can own
property and that to me is a structure
that has continued throughout from a
time when women didn't have the same
legal rights as men to now when they
mostly do but culture still lags behind
it i don't think you and i are
necessarily talking at such cross
purposes it's just that your conception
of patriarchy i see it in the book is
that quite a lot of men are quite nice
and they do nice things for women no
that's not my conception of patriarchy
and i don't require men or advise them
to be nice
well you do talk about the guy who's the
tampon king the sanitary towel king of
india right i wouldn't call that nice
okay
brave okay did you read about his life
when he was trying to develop that yeah
god it was absolutely miserable and he
did it anyways he freed all sorts of
women as a consequence and i think that
was nice that's courageous that's noble
that's visionary it's not nice i think
it is also nice i think it is also
something that is you know it is
honoring your social obligations
why
is it when
men do something for women
it's like oh that's so nice of you and
they don't think of
the
the things that it took to do that and
say like
like i appreciate it more and i'm not
saying all women do this but it's like
that's nice of you because you're
supposed to be able to do something for
me like why
why is that it's it's our society it's
everything i'm telling you once you see
it you can't unsee it like everything is
just geared towards women
everything and anytime a man does
something great they minimize it or try
to say a woman did it
too is true
i have
i have done that before and i'm like
why a woman's done that yeah
but like and i don't think it's because
like people are like i don't think you
were being like an unkind person i just
think like we like that that's we've
been
i hate to say it but like brainwashed
from such a young age to like think like
this yeah
man just red pill stuff
um i'm not so sure that that's a social
obligation because many other people
would have done it had it been a social
obligation
he said what he was concerned about he
saw that his wife was suffering with her
monthly period and
had to choose between feeding her family
and taking care of herself properly and
chose to feed her family and thought he
would do something about that that goes
way past nice especially given what he
had to suffer through to do all the
experimentation that produced his his
eventual technology so like i this whole
patriarchy thing i think you have no
idea how pernicious and dangerous it is